yoshiro mori podría finalmente marcharse
medios japoneses informaron este jueves
que morí dimitirá el viernes de su cargo
de presidente del comité organizador de
los juegos olímpicos de tokio la
decisión se produce después de sus
comentarios sexistas sobre las mujeres
el presidente de la organización dijo en
una reunión a puertas cerradas del
comité olímpico japonés que las mujeres
hablan demasiado y se dejan llevar por
un fuerte sentido de la rivalidad
con respecto a mi intervención de ayer
reconozco que va en contra del espíritu
de los juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos y
que fue inapropiada a la joven ya está
con él
el ex primer ministro nipón se disculpó
unos días después de que se conocieran
sus opiniones pero se negó a dimitir sus
declaraciones desataron una tormenta de
críticas dentro y fuera del país este
jueves los habitantes de tokio acogieron
con satisfacción la noticia de su
dimisión
no se puede perdonar a este hombre
después de hacer esos comentarios además
no puedo tolerar que esta persona
represente a japón en los juegos
olímpicos' así que creo que es bueno
se espera que la decisión se anuncie el
viernes cuando se reúna la junta
directiva del comité organizador entre
los posibles sucesores resalta en varios
medios el nombre de saburó kawaguchi
presidente de la federación nacional de
fútbol una nueva sacudida para tokio
2021 que se suma a las dudas sobre la
viabilidad de los juegos este mismo año